I am very good at hiring because I've
made a lot of mistakes.
I learned to look at the specific
individual and look for the most
important traits in them and ignore
everything else,
especially the resume.
Send you in the wrong direction.
I learned through trial and error what
makes a great manager,
what makes a great salesperson,
and that's who I always are.
If you're going to hire a lot of
salespeople for your organization,
I found that I looked for the same three
things in every single person I hired.
I wanted someone who was insecure with
something,
approve.
If somebody walks in,
they're cocky.
They never become.
Your great salespeople.
Might top 10 salespeople making millions
of dollars a year.
Every year came to my office in
December,
swearing.
They would never have another good year.
Why?
It was ridiculous,
but they were insecure enough to think
it could never happen again.
You want an insecure person.
If you're hiring a salesperson with
something to prove.
You also want someone who has a positive
attitude in every way because you know
what happens.
A positive person when they get hit and
sales is all about getting hit and
knocked down,
they spend very little time feeling
sorry for themselves.
They get right back up that backout you
almost need a low Iq like hit me again,
hit me again,
hit me again.
That's a great salesperson and then you
need the work ethic to go with it.
Nobody is great and sale unless they
work like crazy.
So those are the three traits I look for
in every great salesperson.
What I look for in a manager is someone
who's going to be loyal.
I mean heck,
if I'm going to build a giant house,
which is my business on a shaky
foundation,
how far am I going to get?
I need a structure with a footing is
loyal as can be,
is going to stand there through the
thick and thin.
I also need someone who believes that
we're going to succeed.
I need someone with a positive attitude,
always a positive attitude because you
know what I find,
I find a manager with a positive
attitude is always going to find a way
to get to where you want them to go.
A mark of a good manager is someone
who's organized.
I always ask everyone I'm interviewing
in an interview.
On a scale of one to 10,
how would you rate yourself as an
organized person?
I never hire anyone who says nine or 10.
I want the guy who says,
oh,
I'm bad at 12.
A manager without follow through is
useless.
You gotta be able to give the command.
They get it done and they don't forget
about it when something distracts them.
A manager always follows through.